si en efecto pues el hospital que
nosotros dirigimos es uno de los más
grandes a nivel nacional y en este
momento el hospital tiene una situación
que es muy característica que estamos
viviendo una doble función porque
atendemos pacientes cubrir pero también
atendemos pacientes no kobe y eso nos ha
llevado a un punto donde estamos ahora
en esta saturación en este cansancio del
área hospitalaria de los médicos debido
a que nosotros estamos en este momento
sirviendo para las dos situaciones
entonces hoy por hoy tenemos
aproximadamente por arriba del 130 por
ciento ocupación en nuestro área de
encamamiento de cubrir y pues el área de
severos ha estado pues bastante por
arriba del porcentaje de mire que éste
lo habíamos diseñado entonces realmente
en estos momentos en los médicos están
cansados ya están en un síndrome de
burnout y nosotros realmente
administrativamente es complicado poder
tener todos los instrumentos y dad con
que se están consumiendo dentro de
nuestros hospitales
también le preguntamos a qué se debe la
lentitud en la vacunación y en guatemala
donde sólo un 6% de la población ha sido
inmunizada esto fue lo que nos dijo
bueno la vacunación inició de una forma
muy lenta debido a que el sistema coachs
no nos había entregado como de bienes
entregado y como estaba planificado
luego se hicieron algunas compras a
nivel de gobierno de rusia para
entregarla sputnik y nosotros hemos
estado pues esperando y cómo nos van
entregando haciendo esas entregas
parciales que hemos estado recibiendo
entonces la lentitud con que estamos
recibiendo este estos embarques de las
vacunas pues nos ha dificultado poder
hacer esta situación gracias a ellos
tenemos muchos países hermanos que nos
han donado la vacuna y hemos podido ir
avanzando en la vacunación hoy por hoy
están reportado con primera dosis más o
menos cuatro millones y medio de
guatemaltecos y esperamos poder avanzar
más en este en estos momentos y también
hemos estado invitando a la población a
que se pueda vacunar debido a que
también hemos tenido un poco el problema
de que no han querido acudir a la
vacunación en algunas partes de
guatemala y nos ha costado mucho algunas
regiones pues según creencias no han
querido aceptar la vacunación y eso lo
que estamos tratando en estos momentos
por último nos explicó cuáles son las
solicitudes del sector de salud al
gobierno nacional para evitar un colapso
peor aún en el sistema sanitario
bueno específicamente lo que necesitamos
es una tregua con el virus pueda planear
esa curva que estamos en estos momentos
es tan complicado queremos poder
disminuir los casos en estos momentos y
la verdad es de que estamos tratando y
pidiendo a la población que se cuide
nosotros estamos cargando hacer hasta lo
imposible dentro de los hospitales
necesitamos más personal médico más
personal paramédico de terapistas
respiratorios que es una situación tan
complicada en guatemala que no hemos
tenido suficiente y pues estamos
tratando de que esta situación podamos
solventar la con este tipo de
contrataciones para darle un respiro al
personal que actualmente está debemos de
apostar a la vacunación y que esto
avance para poder mejorar pero también
la población debe hacer su parte ya que
están muy relajados están haciendo
fiestas están haciendo reuniones y eso
nos está sobre cómo complicando de vida
esta variante del está que ha ingresado
que es mucho más efectiva que está
haciendo que la que la infección corra
más rápido dentro de los pueblos y eso
nos está llevando al colapso que tenemos
en estos momentos